in today's video i'll give you 10 games
to play while you're waiting for
hogwarts legacy
retrorecontour here i'm just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell
and like so many of you
i'm eagerly awaiting the release of
hogwarts legacy but there are so
many video games released these days
there are plenty we can play in the
meantime to fill that void until
hogwarts legacy finally arrives sometime
in 2022
each of these titles contains at least
some element i feel would appeal to fans
of harry potter and those looking
forward to hogwarts legacy
some have really good stories whereas
others are action rpgs like
hogwarts legacy some on the list are
fairly recent and
others are pretty old if you decide you
want to pick up any of these titles i'll
have links down in the description box
below
number one the old harry potter games
okay we might as well start with the
obvious ones right because if you
haven't played any of the old harry
potter games there are actually quite a
few worth playing even if they aren't
out of this world great games i've
played quite a few of them over the
years in fact i'm actually doing a let's
play
right now here on the channel if you're
curious you can check that out as well
the easiest ones to get your hands on
these days are the lego harry potter
games which are available on
all the major consoles as well as pc as
for the older console on pc games and
unfortunately they're a little difficult
to find but google and reddit can help
you there
you can always look to buy secondhand
physical copies through a local game
shop or ebay
i recently purchased a ps3 copy of order
of the phoenix on ebay for around 15
bucks
you can probably find them pretty cheap
my personal favorites are the original
sorcerer stone game on pc
the console version of chamber of
secrets and the previously mentioned
order of the phoenix
all the lego games are pretty good as
well but once you've played one of those
lego games you kind of know what you're
getting into with all
a lot of folks are partial to the wii
version of order of the phoenix but if
the novelty of motion controls has worn
off for you
if it has for me you can stick to one of
the other versions instead
sadly i think most fans feel as if we
are still waiting for a truly
great harry potter game while a lot of
these games are enjoyable in their own
way i personally don't feel that any of
them truly lived up to the potential of
what a harry potter game can be
so no pressure hogwarts legacy the
history of the royal
family of hyrule is also the history of
the calamity ganon number two the legend
of zelda breath of the wild
if you have a nintendo switch then
chances are you're already one of the 22
million who have purchased the game
but if you haven't played it yet you
should change that as soon as
possible heck even if you've already
played it's worth playing again or going
back to your original save to try and
complete more quests
overall the zelda series probably has
more in common with fantasy titles like
lure the rings
but harry potter fans will no doubt
enjoy the vast exploration and freedom
you have with such an open game like
breath of the wild
of course there are magic items and
abilities link obtains throughout his
journey as well
where the game really shines is in the
freedom it gives you to solve
problems and complete challenges using
the magic and abilities at your disposal
even years after its release people were
still finding different ways to
accomplish tasks throughout the game
[Music]
number three persona 4 golden persona 4
is the first persona game i played and
yes i played
the ps vita version long live the vida
persona 4 is a japanese rpg developed by
atlas and you'll play as a high school
student who starts investigating a
series of mysterious murders
the appeal here for harry potter fans is
in the relationships and drama between
high school teenagers persona 4 has a
unique social link system where
developing your friendships will yield
bonuses and enhancements during battle
the kicker is like the real world
there's only so much time in the day so
you can't spend time with every single
friend
you'll have to choose who you spend your
time with admittedly the game
is long but the story is riveting it's
characters fun and interesting and the
persona battle system is one i really
enjoy
at number four we have ori and the blind
forest this one completely shifting
gears from something like persona
ori on the other hand is a
side-scrolling platformer that also has
elements of something like metroid or
castlevania you'll unlock an upgrade
abilities along your journey through the
game with absolutely
gorgeous graphics the art here is just
staggering
all of these elements combine to help
tell what is a touching story that i
really think will resonate with harry
potter fans
[Applause]
at number five we have the witcher 3
wild hunt
look you knew it had to be on the list
fantasy game
in the action rpg genre hogwarts legacy
fans if you haven't played this one yet
you gotta give it a shot it's based on a
series of polish novels so it's no
surprise that the video game version is
rich with a deep backstory
interesting characters and a well
thought out magic system
personally i'm not a huge fan of the
combat and how it controls overall but
everything else is an absolute 10 out of
10 for me
seriously this would probably be my
favorite game ever made if it had the
combat of something like dark souls
the level of detail throughout the world
is just staggering you'll have
choices and dialogue options throughout
that let you control how you want to
handle certain confrontations
wild hunt also has some of the best side
quests in
any game i've played there are side
quests here with completely dynamic
characters and overall the side quests
feel
even more fleshed out than something you
would see in an entire game
if you're a fan of good stories epic
fantasy and using magic then you owe it
to yourself to give the witcher 3 a try
number six we're gonna completely shift
gears yet again
and say animal crossing new horizons
look i admit this may seem like an odd
recommendation for harry potter fans
it's not an action rpg you don't really
use
magic so what's the appeal here i've
personally found there to be some
overlap between
harry potter and animal crossing fans
for those of you very familiar with my
channel here you know i have quite a few
animal crossing videos in addition to
the harry potter ones
so what is it about animal crossing that
appeals to so many harry potter fans for
me i think a lot of it is about the
creativity you have in animal crossing
you can design areas that look like
hogwarts castle decorate your house to
look like the common room of your choice
and of course you can dress like a
wizard as well
you can also design clothing to
represent your favorite house or
quidditch team
and look we all know the harry potter
series provided a great escape from the
real world for so many of us and animal
crossing really does the same
it's a calming slower paced game that's
more about the overall experience than
trying to complete objective after
objective
in their tongue dragonborn
number seven the elder scrolls 5 skyrim
skyrim was the first elder scrolls game
i ever played and it completely
blew me away from the first moment i had
control of my character
i went straight for the college of
winterhold where i had heard you could
learn
magic what awaited me there was a series
of stories and missions that could have
been an entire game
on their own the world felt alive and i
truly felt a bond forming between my
player and the other characters at the
college
there's plenty of magic for harry potter
fans and an expansive lore about the
world and creatures to go along with it
it's true skyrim is one of the older
titles on the list but if you have yet
to play
i highly recommend it ashton won
here is thou my voice still
number eight dark souls three if you're
looking for something that's a little
more challenging than what we've had so
far on the list
look no further than the soul series i
went with dark souls 3 for the list here
even though
one is probably my favorite overall but
you can't go wrong with either of them
definitely would not recommend starting
with two though dark souls 3 has some of
the
best bosses in the entire series and yes
there's plenty
of magic bloodborne and demon souls are
also fantastic
honestly bloodborne is probably my
favorite souls game overall but since
this is a list
specifically for harry potter fans i
went with a souls game here because they
do
have more magic overall than what you
would see in something like bloodborne
and if you can get your hands on a ps5
then the demon souls remaster is
absolutely fantastic
find your way home number nine god of
war
the 2018 version of god of war
completely reinvented the series in
all the right ways pulling elements from
both greek and norse mythology there's
both magic
and creatures that will certainly please
harry potter fans
as good as the action is in the new god
of war though the series also
incorporated more upgradability and
freedom in the abilities you unlock
but the heart of the game is absolutely
the relationship between kratos and his
son atreus
harry longed for a father figure
throughout the entire harry potter
series and frequently sought the
approval of the prominent male
influences in his life
such as dumbledore lupin and of course
sirius
seeing kratos and atreus bond throughout
the adventure and playing out their
journey with some
epic moments of action is one of the
most impactful moments i've had in
gaming
over the past decade
number 10 star wars knights of the old
republic
and here we have one of my favorite
action rpgs of all time
there's actually been some chatter that
hogwarts legacy will have elements
inspired by knights of the old republic
and let me tell you i'd certainly love
it if that were the case
this is another older one on our list
but still definitely worth playing i
would say there's one key element here
that this one has over any of the others
on our list
and that's the sense of choice yes
choice is present in some of the other
games but here
it really stands out through various
dialogue choices and a somewhat
branching story knights of the old
republic gave players the ability to
become a good jedi
or an evil sith there were also unique
abilities based on your path of choice
and for anyone who's already played it
you guys already know the epic twist at
the end
rivals that it was plural moment that we
had in sorcerer's stone
these days you can usually find this one
and its sequel for pretty cheap over on
steam
and you know what i'm going to throw in
one bonus option for the multiplayer
fans out there and that would be
spell break instead of guns with spell
break this is a title focused on
spell casting to take down your
opponents you can choose to wield fire
as a pyromancer
shift the earth as a stone shaper poison
foes as the toxicologist
electrify enemies as a conduit freeze
foes as a frostborn or do your best
airbender impersonation as the tempest
class
this one is actually free to play as
well and it's available on all major
platforms so if it sounds like something
you'd be interested in there's no reason
not to try
which of the games on this list are your
favorite and do you have any other
recommendations for your fellow harry
potter fans out there
i want to hear it in the comments below
so let me know and as always guys thank
you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon